Our episodes deal with serious and often distressing incidents. If you feel at any time you need support, please contact your local crisis centre. For suggested phone numbers for confidential support and for a more detailed list of content warnings, please see the show notes for this episode on your app or on our website. The capital of the state of Western Australia, Perth, has long been referred to as the most isolated city in the world. While there is some debate as to whether this title is accurate, the fact remains that Perth is the only large city in a circuit of more than 2,000 kilometres.
我们的节目涉及严肃且往往令人痛苦的事件。如果您在任何时候感到需要支持，请联系您当地的危机中心。如需获取保密支持的建议电话号码以及更详细的内容警告列表，请查看您在应用程序或我们网站上本集节目的节目说明。西澳大利亚州首府珀斯长期以来被称为世界上最与世隔绝的城市。虽然关于这个称号是否准确尚存争议，但事实是，珀斯是方圆2000多公里内唯一的城市。
It sits on the other side of the country to the more heavily populated eastern states home to Sydney, Melbourne and Brisbane, and the next nearest capital city is South Australia's Adelaide, a 28-hour drive away. Perth is located in the lower western corner of the state and is adjacent to the Indian Ocean. Another body of water, the Swan River, cuts through the middle of Perth, dividing the city in two with much of the central business district built up along its banks. East of the city is home to sprawling hills and parklands filled with the native flora and iconic Australian bush. Winters in Perth are mild, reaching a top temperature of 19 degrees Celsius on average, while the summers are renowned for their dry heat.
它位于该国与人口稠密的东部各州（悉尼、墨尔本和布里斯班所在地）相对的一侧，距离最近的下一个首府城市是南澳大利亚州的阿德莱德，车程需28小时。珀斯位于该州西南部角落，毗邻印度洋。另一片水域天鹅河穿过珀斯中部，将城市一分为二，大部分中央商务区都沿河岸而建。城市东部拥有绵延的丘陵和公园，长满了本土植物和标志性的澳大利亚灌木。珀斯的冬天温和，平均最高气温为19摄氏度，而夏天则以干燥炎热而闻名。
In the warmer months, swimmers and surfers flock to Perth's coastline to enjoy popular beaches such as Coddersloe and Scarborough. During the late 1950s, the city was home to about 388,000 people, but was rapidly growing due to a baby boom and post-World War II migration. Even as the city expanded and swelled, a sense of innocence remained. Nights were quieter. Strict licensing laws meant that pubs closed by 9pm. Dance halls and concerts were a favourite weekend pastime for the city's youth,
在温暖的月份，游泳者和冲浪者蜂拥至珀斯的海岸线，享受科特斯洛和斯卡伯勒等热门海滩。20世纪50年代末，该市约有38.8万人口，但由于婴儿潮和二战后的移民潮，人口迅速增长。即使在城市扩张和膨胀的过程中，一种纯真感依然存在。夜晚更加安静。严格的许可法意味着酒吧在晚上9点前必须关门。舞厅和音乐会是该市年轻人最喜欢的周末消遣方式，
but they too were governed by restrictions that typically saw the entertainment wind down before midnight. Homes were kept unlocked with windows open even at night, drivers parked their cars with the keys in the ignition, and residents were never more than a couple of degrees of separation from one another. However, this sense of security and safety that residents took for granted would be shaken and then irrevocably damaged as the city entered the 1960s. Under the cover of darkness, Perth was terrorised by an elusive figure, someone who would eventually be dubbed the Nightcaller. Towards the end of the 1950s, households throughout Perth experienced an uptick in burglaries. Residents would return home from being away or wake in the morning to find that
但它们也受到限制，通常在午夜前娱乐活动就会结束。家门不锁，窗户即使在晚上也开着，司机停车时钥匙留在点火开关里，居民之间彼此的距离从未超过几度。然而，随着城市进入20世纪60年代，这种居民认为理所当然的安全感将被动摇，并受到不可挽回的破坏。在夜幕的掩护下，珀斯被一个难以捉摸的人物所恐吓，他最终被称为“夜间呼叫者”。20世纪50年代末，珀斯各地的家庭入室盗窃案有所增加。居民从外地回家或早上醒来时发现，
someone had been in their house overnight. Cash that had been left lying around or stashed inside wallets and purses was missing. It could range from a few shillings to pound notes, as Australia was using the pound currency at the time. Sometimes money was even missing from hiding places such as drawers or inside an ornamental vase. Small objects of varying value were also pocketed. Watches, pens, jewelry, and even a torch were taken. More disturbingly, women had their underwear stolen. Police reports were typically filed when the crimes were discovered, but officers were left stumped by the lack of fingerprints at any of the crime scenes. Other times, residents were entirely unaware that they'd had an intruder at all.
有人在他们睡觉时进过屋。放在外面或藏在钱包和手袋里的现金不见了。金额从几先令到英镑不等，因为当时澳大利亚使用的是英镑。有时，钱甚至是从抽屉或装饰花瓶等藏身处丢失的。各种价值的小物件也被顺手牵羊。手表、钢笔、珠宝，甚至手电筒都被拿走了。更令人不安的是，女性的内衣被偷了。犯罪被发现后，通常会向警方报案，但由于所有犯罪现场都没有指纹，警官们束手无策。有时，居民根本不知道自己家里进了贼。
Sometimes, so little of importance was taken that it was never missed or was assumed to have been misplaced. These seemed like the crimes of an opportunistic offender seeking financial gain, taking advantage of the lack security measures in place. During this time, there were also sightings and reports of a prowler in central and southern Perth. A man was spotted lurking in the bushes, peeping in windows and loitering outside of apartment blocks. Sometimes his footprints were discovered in garden beds the following morning.
有时，被拿走的东西太不重要，以至于从未被发现丢失，或者被认为是放错了地方。这些看起来像是投机取巧的罪犯为了经济利益而犯下的罪行，利用了当时缺乏安全措施的漏洞。在此期间，珀斯中部和南部也出现了徘徊者的踪迹和报告。有人看到一名男子潜伏在灌木丛中，窥视窗户，并在公寓楼外游荡。有时第二天早上在花园里会发现他的脚印。
Occasionally, women's nightgowns and underwear left hanging on washing lines were found cut and slashed. No one could know that a single person was behind all of these crimes, which were typically written off as minor offences. There was seemingly nothing violent about them, but that would soon change. but that would soon change. The MacLeod family lived in the riverside suburb of Applecross, close to Perth's CBD and just across the Swan River. In the early hours of Wednesday November 26, 1958, Lucy and Ern MacLeod were woken by a strange commotion in their bedroom. Lucy and Ern MacLeod were woken by a strange commotion in their bedroom.
偶尔，晾衣绳上挂着的女性睡袍和内衣会被割破。没有人能想到，所有这些通常被视为轻微犯罪的案件背后竟然是同一个人。这些犯罪看起来似乎没有任何暴力成分，但这种情况很快就会改变。麦克劳德一家住在天鹅河畔的苹果十字区，靠近珀斯中央商务区，就在天鹅河对面。1958年11月26日星期三凌晨，露西和恩·麦克劳德被卧室里的一阵奇怪动静惊醒。
Their daughter, 15-year-old Molly, was wandering around the room, tripping over her own feet and retching as though she was going to vomit. Molly rambled incoherently, clearly trying to tell her parents something, but she couldn't form the words to speak. Terrified, Lucy rushed to her child, who had been fine when she'd gone to bed the previous evening. Lucy and Erne repeatedly asked Molly what had happened, begging her to explain what was wrong. Molly was unable to answer and soon lost consciousness. Her father carried her back to her room, which was a sleep out that adjoined the family's kitchen, and gently laid her in bed. Lucy kneeled beside Molly and
他们15岁的女儿莫莉在房间里走来走去，被自己的脚绊倒，干呕着，好像要呕吐一样。莫莉语无伦次地嘟囔着，显然想告诉父母什么，但她说不出话来。惊恐万分的露西冲向她的孩子，孩子前一天晚上睡觉时还好好的。露西和恩反复问莫莉发生了什么事，恳求她解释哪里不舒服。莫莉无法回答，很快就失去了知觉。她的父亲把她抱回了她的房间（那是连接家庭厨房的一个睡房），轻轻地把她放在床上。露西跪在莫莉身边，
held a set of rosary beads in her hand, praying repeatedly for her daughter's health. To her parents' relief, Molly regained consciousness, though she continued to moan and mumble without making any sense. By morning, Molly was able to string a few words together, enough to tell her parents that her head hurt. One of her eyes had turned black, suggesting she'd somehow received a knock to the head. had turned black, suggesting she'd somehow received a knock to the head. Lucy McLeod took Molly to the family doctor, who was unable to ascertain the cause of Molly's injury, but diagnosed her as having a concussion and a hairline skull fracture. It took Molly more than a month to recover. A staff student, she had been due to finish high school but was unable to attend her leaving exams. Meanwhile, her family was puzzled over the mystery behind
手里拿着一串念珠，反复为女儿的健康祈祷。令父母欣慰的是，莫莉恢复了知觉，尽管她仍然呻吟和嘟囔着，让人听不懂。到了早上，莫莉能连贯地说出几个词，足以告诉父母她头痛。她的一只眼睛变成了黑色，暗示她头部受到了撞击。露西·麦克劳德带莫莉去看家庭医生，医生无法确定莫莉受伤的原因，但诊断她患有脑震荡和颅骨裂纹骨折。莫莉花了一个多月才康复。作为一名优等生，她本应完成高中学业，但却无法参加毕业考试。与此同时，她的家人对她严重头部受伤背后的谜团感到困惑。
what caused her severe head injury. They eventually concluded that Molly must have received the knock after an awful nightmare caused her to fall out of bed. Molly and her family had no idea that she had actually crossed paths with the night caller. He had slipped into the MacLeod's Applecross home as its residents slept. He prowled about, looking for cash he could steal, and helped himself to some money he found in the kitchen. As he was opening the back door to escape, his grip on the handle slipped and the noise woke Molly, whose bed was right next door. Seeing the girl stir, the night caller grabbed a nearby object and hit her over the head with it before fleeing. Throughout December 1958 and into the new year, the night caller continued to stalk the streets of Perth. Weekends seemed to be when he was most
他们最终得出结论，莫莉一定是在做了一场可怕的噩梦后从床上摔下来才受的伤。莫莉和她的家人根本不知道她实际上与“夜间呼叫者”擦肩而过。他溜进了麦克劳德在苹果十字区的家中，趁居民熟睡时潜入。他在屋里徘徊，寻找可以偷的现金，并拿走了他在厨房里发现的一些钱。当他打开后门准备逃跑时，手滑了一下，发出的声音惊醒了睡在隔壁的莫莉。看到女孩动弹，夜间呼叫者抓起附近的一个物体朝她头上打去，然后逃之夭夭。1958年12月至新年期间，夜间呼叫者继续在珀斯的街道上徘徊。周末似乎是他最
active, though he also ventured out on Tuesday and Thursday evenings. His crimes were growing ever more brazen. At 3am one night, a 21-year-old school teacher who lived in Millpoint Road, South Perth was woken by a strange man grabbing her by the neck and scratching her face. She screamed and the intruder jumped out of her bedroom window. Six weeks after this attack, on Wednesday, January 28, Perth reached its warmest day of the year when the temperature reached 43 degrees Celsius, or 109 degrees Fahrenheit. That night, a man who lived one street over from where the teacher had been attacked heard a noise outside at 1.50am and went to investigate. His sudden appearance disturbed a man trying to break in via the back door. The prowler flared
活跃的时候，尽管他也会在周二和周四晚上出没。他的罪行越来越猖狂。一天凌晨3点，一位住在南珀斯米尔波特路的一名21岁女教师被一个陌生男子惊醒，他抓住她的脖子并抓伤了她的脸。她尖叫起来，入侵者从她的卧室窗户跳了出去。这次袭击六周后，即1月28日星期三，珀斯迎来了全年最热的一天，气温达到43摄氏度（109华氏度）。那天晚上，住在女教师遇袭地点隔壁街的一名男子在凌晨1点50分听到外面有动静，便去查看。他的突然出现惊动了一个试图从后门闯入的男子。徘徊者
on foot. A neighbour who had also spotted him watching a block of flats from a nearby phone booth described him as being between 5 foot 8 and 5'10 with thick dark hair. The following day of Thursday January 29, 33-year-old Penina Berkman worked a shift at the perfume counter of the David Jones department store in Perth CBD. Penina had relocated to Perth from Melbourne four years earlier after she and her husband divorced. Penina had settled into a ground floor apartment on Millpoint Road in South Perth and was happy there.
徒步逃跑。一位邻居也曾看到他在附近的电话亭观察一栋公寓楼，描述他身高在5英尺8英寸到5英尺10英寸之间，留着浓密的黑发。第二天，即1月29日星期四，33岁的佩妮娜·伯克曼在珀斯中央商务区大卫琼斯百货公司的香水柜台值班。佩妮娜在四年前与丈夫离婚后从墨尔本搬到了珀斯。佩妮娜在南珀斯的米尔波特路定居在一间一楼的公寓里，在那里生活得很开心。
Even though her flat had been broken into about six months earlier and 35 shillings were stolen, Penina was comfortable in her new city. She was a glamorous woman who had caught the eye of a local radio DJ named Fotis Huntas. The pair became a couple. They planned to meet up after Penina finished her shift that day. Fotis picked Penina up from David Jones and drove her back to her apartment, where they ate dinner together. Later on, they drank some beer, then went to bed together. At midnight, Fotis got dressed and prepared to head home to sleep. As he left, Penina said goodnight and that she would see him tomorrow. As he left, Penina said goodnight and that she would see him tomorrow.
尽管她的公寓在大约六个月前被闯入并被偷走了35先令，但佩妮娜对她的新城市感到很自在。她是一位迷人的女性，吸引了一位名叫福蒂斯·亨塔斯的当地电台DJ的注意。两人成了情侣。他们计划在佩妮娜那天值班结束后见面。福蒂斯从大卫琼斯接上佩妮娜，开车送她回公寓，两人一起吃了晚饭。后来，他们喝了一些啤酒，然后一起上床睡觉。午夜时分，福蒂斯穿好衣服，准备回家睡觉。他离开时，佩妮娜说了晚安，并说明天见。
Neighbours overheard Fotis' footsteps as he departed the building and heard some other things in the hours that followed. At around 3am, a couple in an apartment next to Penina's were woken by the sound of someone gasping followed by a scream. A few minutes later, they heard a car door slam, then the car driving away. Another resident also heard some screams and a car leaving at around the same time. The next morning, Fotis drove by Panina's apartment on his way to an appointment and noticed that the door was ajar and her bedroom window was open, its curtains blowing in the breeze. Panina often slept with the window open during the hot summer nights, but Fotis knew that she always made a point to close everything and lock up before heading to work. She was supposed to have a shift that day, so the apartment should have been secured. Fotis decided to investigate.
邻居们听到了福蒂斯离开大楼时的脚步声，并在随后的几个小时里听到了一些其他声音。凌晨3点左右，佩妮娜隔壁公寓的一对夫妇被一阵喘息声和随后的尖叫声惊醒。几分钟后，他们听到车门关上的声音，然后汽车开走了。另一位居民也在同一时间左右听到了一些尖叫声和汽车离开的声音。第二天早上，福蒂斯在去赴约的路上开车经过佩妮娜的公寓，发现门半开着，卧室窗户开着，窗帘在微风中飘动。佩妮娜在炎热的夏夜经常开着窗睡觉，但福蒂斯知道她总是会在上班前把所有东西关好并锁上。她那天本应有班，所以公寓应该处于安全状态。福蒂斯决定去查看一下。
Inside, he found Panina on the lounge room floor by the sliding glass doors. She was naked in a pool of blood. She had been stabbed through the nose and in the heart with a knife. It appeared Penina had crawled to the doors in an attempt to escape, but hadn't survived. Nothing was missing from the apartment except for Penina's purse. The murder weapon wasn't recovered. The murder weapon wasn't recovered. The horrific murder sent shockwaves through Perth. Crimes like this were a rarity in the quiet city. Fotis Huentas told police that when he left Panina's apartment she had been naked in bed. It wasn't unusual for her to sleep naked in hot weather. Fotis quickly found himself the case's prime suspect and the public agreed that he seemed suspicious.
在里面，他发现佩妮娜躺在滑动玻璃门旁的客厅地板上。她赤身裸体，倒在血泊中。她的鼻子和心脏被刀刺穿。看起来佩妮娜曾试图爬向门口逃生，但没能活下来。公寓里除了佩妮娜的钱包外，什么都没丢。凶器没有找到。这起可怕的谋杀案在珀斯引起了轰动。这样的罪行在这个安静的城市里很少见。福蒂斯·亨塔斯告诉警方，他离开佩妮娜的公寓时，她赤身裸体躺在床上。她在炎热的天气里裸睡并不罕见。福蒂斯很快发现自己成了案件的主要嫌疑人，公众也认为他看起来很可疑。
When Fotis left Perth to return to his birth country of Greece, their suspicions were all but confirmed. Panina's killer had gotten away. Even though Panina lived on the same street where a 21-year-old teacher had been attacked in her own home just six weeks earlier, police didn't consider that her murder could be part of a larger picture. They reassured worried Perth residents, stating, They reassured worried Perth residents, stating, The public have no need to be feared from the activities of the person who killed Panina Berkman, and they can forget all about the existence of that person. Residents of Perth's western suburbs felt somewhat detached from the murder of Panina Berkman
当福蒂斯离开珀斯回到他的出生国希腊时，他们的怀疑几乎得到了证实。佩妮娜的凶手逃脱了。尽管佩妮娜住的那条街上，六周前刚有一名21岁的女教师在自己家中遇袭，但警方并没有认为她的谋杀案可能是一个更大图景的一部分。他们安抚了担忧的珀斯居民，称：“公众无需担心杀害佩妮娜·伯克曼的人的活动，他们可以完全忘记那个人的存在。”珀斯西郊的居民对佩妮娜·伯克曼的谋杀案感到有些疏远，
as she had been living in South Perth. Although that wasn't far in terms of distance, it almost felt like another world due to the Swan River providing a geographical buffer. Moreover, the Inar western suburbs were an affluent and insular pocket that felt particularly safe with a tight-knit community. One of these wealthy suburbs was Netherlands, an attractive neighbourhood just seven kilometres west of the CBD. Dotted with nice houses and lots of parks, Netherlands was also close to the University of Western Australia. This made it a popular
因为她住在南珀斯。虽然从距离上看并不远，但由于天鹅河提供了地理缓冲，感觉就像是另一个世界。此外，内西郊是一个富裕且封闭的区域，拥有紧密的社区，感觉特别安全。这些富裕郊区之一是内德兰兹，这是一个距离中央商务区仅七公里的迷人社区。内德兰兹点缀着漂亮的房子和许多公园，也靠近西澳大利亚大学。这使它成为一个受欢迎的
suburb for students who primarily lived in the area's apartment buildings. In August 1959, Alex Donkin was a first-year nursing student who was staying at her elder sister's flat in Nedlands. Saturday August 8 was going to be a break from Alex's busy work and study schedule. Some friends from her hometown were visiting for the weekend, and Alex was looking forward to seeing them. Alex and her friends spent the evening at a drive-in cinema, then headed back to Alex's flat to drink coffee and listen to records. At 12.45am, Alex's guests left and she got ready for bed. A security conscious person, Alex made sure to lock the front door and close all the windows. The exception was one narrow window in the kitchen which led to
郊区，学生们主要住在该地区的公寓楼里。1959年8月，亚历克斯·唐金是一名一年级护理系学生，住在她姐姐在内德兰兹的公寓里。8月8日星期六本应是亚历克斯繁忙的工作和学习计划中的休息日。她家乡的一些朋友周末来访，亚历克斯很期待见到他们。亚历克斯和她的朋友们在汽车电影院度过了晚上，然后回到亚历克斯的公寓喝咖啡、听唱片。凌晨12点45分，亚历克斯的客人们离开了，她准备睡觉。作为一个有安全意识的人，亚历克斯确保锁好前门并关上所有窗户。唯一的例外是厨房里的一扇窄窗，通向
an outdoor landing. Because the window was so narrow, Alex felt comfortable leaving it slightly ajar while she slept. The following morning, Alex's friends from out of town headed over to her flat for a planned visit. George and Hedley were both farmers who lived in Western Australia's wheat belt about an hour and a half outside of Perth. The young men knocked on the door and were shocked when Alex opened it. Her face and hair were soaked with blood due to a deep wound over her left eye. Still wearing her pyjamas, Alex was disoriented and clearly oblivious to the injury. George and Headley searched the apartment. Alex's pillow was drenched with blood and her purse was
一个室外平台。因为窗户很窄，亚历克斯觉得睡觉时稍微开着它很舒服。第二天早上，亚历克斯的外地朋友来到她的公寓进行计划中的访问。乔治和赫德利都是农民，住在珀斯外约一个半小时车程的西澳大利亚小麦带。年轻人们敲了敲门，当亚历克斯打开门时，他们惊呆了。她的脸和头发都被血浸透了，左眼上方有一道深深的伤口。亚历克斯仍然穿着睡衣，神志不清，显然没有意识到自己受了伤。乔治和赫德利搜查了公寓。亚历克斯的枕头被血浸透了，她的钱包
missing. She told George and Headley that there had been six pounds inside the purse, but she struggled to answer other questions. When asked about the previous night, Alex said she'd woken up at 3.30am then fallen back asleep. She couldn't recall anything else. George and Headley couldn't see any sign of forced entry, but it was clear their friend had been attacked and robbed. They arranged to take Alex to the doctor. An examination revealed she also sustained a small fracture to the back of her skull. That, plus the injury above her eye, indicated she'd been hit twice. The attack left Alex with the severe epilepsy that she would need to treat with medication for the rest of her life. She was unable to continue her studies or achieve her
不见了。她告诉乔治和赫德利钱包里有六英镑，但她很难回答其他问题。当被问及前一天晚上时，亚历克斯说她在凌晨3点30分醒来，然后又睡着了。她记不起其他任何事情。乔治和赫德利没有看到任何强行闯入的迹象，但很明显他们的朋友遭到了袭击和抢劫。他们安排带亚历克斯去看医生。检查显示她颅骨后部也有一处小骨折。加上她眼睛上方的伤口，表明她被击中了两次。这次袭击给亚历克斯留下了严重的癫痫，她余生都需要药物治疗。她无法继续学业或实现她
dream of becoming a nurse. Alex's uncle was a special investigator in the police's criminal investigation branch and the attack against his niece was taken very seriously. Officers searched the apartment but found no fingerprints. A poker was missing from the fireplace which they speculated could have been used to inflict Alex's injuries. They took note that the kitchen window was the only point of entry for an intruder. Yet with no evidence leading to a specific person, there was little they could do.
成为护士的梦想。亚历克斯的叔叔是警方刑事调查部门的一名特别调查员，他侄女受到的袭击被非常严肃地对待。警官们搜查了公寓，但没有发现指纹。壁炉里的拨火棍不见了，他们推测这可能被用来造成亚历克斯的伤害。他们注意到厨房窗户是入侵者唯一的进入点。然而，由于没有证据指向特定的人，他们能做的很少。
Four months later, residents of Perth were preparing for another sun-soaked summer. One week before Christmas on Saturday December 19, 22-year-old Gillian Brewer invited her fiance over to her home in Brookwood Flats, a two-storey red brick apartment complex in the beachside suburb of Coddersloe. Gillian was well known in Perth as a socialite and an heiress whose great-grandfather had founded the chocolate company McRobertson's Confectionery. After growing up in Melbourne and beginning a career in interior design, Gillian had flown west to Perth at the age of 21. She was happy in her new city, settling into an apartment next door to her mother's and living with her small French poodle, Dior, for company. Gillian would be getting married in two months time to her 31-year-old fiance, Andrew, not his real name.
四个月后，珀斯居民正准备迎接另一个阳光明媚的夏天。圣诞节前一周，即12月19日星期六，22岁的吉莉安·布鲁尔邀请她的未婚夫到她位于科特斯洛海滨郊区的两层红砖公寓大楼布鲁克伍德公寓的家中。吉莉安在珀斯是一位著名的社交名媛和女继承人，她的曾祖父创立了麦克罗伯逊糖果公司。在墨尔本长大并开始室内设计职业生涯后，吉莉安在21岁时飞往西部的珀斯。她在新城市生活得很开心，搬进了她母亲隔壁的公寓，并和她的小法国贵宾犬迪奥住在一起。吉莉安将在两个月后与她31岁的未婚夫安德鲁（化名）结婚。
Andrew and Gillian spent that Saturday together before returning to her apartment for the evening. Gillian's flat was on the ground floor and at the back of the complex. Andrew went home at around midnight with the plan to play golf with Jillian the next day. At 9am, Andrew went to pick Jillian up and found her front door locked. This was unusual, as she mostly kept it open when she was up. Andrew could see Jillian's poodle Dior jumping up and down frantically at the bedroom window. Andrew had a key to Jillian's apartment in his car, so he went back to get it and then let himself in. The kitchen window was open and a breeze had blown some Christmas cards Jillian had out on display onto the floor. Unusually, the door to Jillian's bedroom was closed.
安德鲁和吉莉安一起度过了那个星期六，然后回到她的公寓过夜。吉莉安的公寓在一楼，位于大楼后面。安德鲁在午夜左右回家，计划第二天和吉莉安去打高尔夫球。早上9点，安德鲁去接吉莉安，发现她的前门锁着。这很不寻常，因为她起床时通常都开着门。安德鲁可以看到吉莉安的贵宾犬迪奥在卧室窗户边疯狂地跳上跳下。安德鲁的车里有吉莉安公寓的钥匙，所以他回去拿了钥匙，然后自己进去了。厨房的窗户开着，微风把吉莉安展示出来的一些圣诞贺卡吹到了地板上。不寻常的是，吉莉安卧室的门关着。
Andrew had never seen it shut before. He opened the door and saw Jillian lying in bed, a sheet pulled all the way up to her chin, and a pillow lying on her chest. Her face was covered in blood, as was the sheet and the wall behind her. Andrew raced next door to Jillian's mother's apartment and called for a doctor. Upon arriving at the scene, the doctor in turn phoned the police. After removing the sheet, officers saw the extent of Jillian's injuries. She was naked and had wounds all over her body that had been inflicted with a hatchet. Her breasts, head and genitals had all been struck. Using the flat side of the hatchet, the killer had also hit Gillian's stomach, thighs, face and throat. This final blow had been hard enough to sever her windpipe.
安德鲁以前从未见过它关着。他打开门，看到吉莉安躺在床上，床单一直拉到下巴，胸口放着一个枕头。她的脸被血覆盖，床单和身后的墙壁也是如此。安德鲁冲到隔壁吉莉安母亲的公寓，叫了医生。医生到达现场后，随即报警。移开床单后，警官们看到了吉莉安受伤的程度。她赤身裸体，全身都有被斧头造成的伤口。她的乳房、头部和生殖器都受到了重击。凶手还用斧头的平侧击打了吉莉安的腹部、大腿、脸部和喉咙。这最后一击力道之大，足以切断她的气管。
Then the killer had used a pair of scissors that belonged to Gillian to stab her five times. of scissors that belonged to Jillian to stab her five times. An autopsy would later reveal that Jillian had likely remained alive for two to three hours after the attack, with the coroner stating it was the worst murder he had ever seen. The killer covered her with a sheet and wiped the scissors clean before returning them to their usual spot. Blood was later found on the inner blades of the scissors, indicating they had been closed when the killer wiped them down. He had taken the hatchet with him and tossed it over the back fence. Police found it lying on the ground on the other side, still covered with the Gillian's blood. ground on the other side, still covered with the Gillian's blood. The killer had been so forceful when using it that the wooden handle was split near the head.
然后凶手用吉莉安的一把剪刀刺了她五次。尸检后来显示，吉莉安在袭击发生后可能还活了两到三个小时，验尸官称这是他见过的最糟糕的谋杀案。凶手用床单盖住她，并在把剪刀放回原处之前将其擦拭干净。后来在剪刀的内刃上发现了血迹，表明凶手擦拭它们时剪刀是合上的。他带走了斧头，把它扔过了后院的栅栏。警察发现它躺在另一边的地上，上面仍然覆盖着吉莉安的血迹。凶手在使用它时用力过猛，以至于木柄在斧头附近裂开了。
The hatchet was found to have been stolen from a home in the street behind Gillian's. There were no clues as to the killer's identity. He hadn't left any fingerprints, and there was no sign of forced entry at Jillian's apartment. Both the front and back doors were locked. None of Jillian's neighbours had seen anything untoward, though a mother and daughter who lived nearby reported hearing Jillian's dog bark at around 1am. The barking abruptly stopped as though someone had reprimanded the animal. In the days that followed, Jillian's murder dominated newspaper headlines. As well as the horror of the crime itself, there was the fact that police didn't have a suspect. In the horror of the crime itself, there was the fact that police didn't have a suspect. No one in Gillian's life was thought to be responsible.
斧头被发现是从吉莉安家后面那条街的一户人家偷来的。没有任何关于凶手身份的线索。他没有留下任何指纹，吉莉安的公寓也没有强行闯入的迹象。前门和后门都锁着。吉莉安的邻居都没有看到任何异常，尽管住在附近的一对母女报告说在凌晨1点左右听到吉莉安的狗叫。叫声突然停止，好像有人训斥了这只动物。在随后的几天里，吉莉安的谋杀案占据了报纸头条。除了犯罪本身的恐怖之外，还有一个事实是警方没有嫌疑人。吉莉安生活中的任何人都被认为不可能是凶手。
Her purse was missing from the apartment, indicating her killer had stolen it. The pathologist who observed Gillian and Panina's bodies noted the similarities between their injuries. Both had been stabbed multiple times while asleep in bed. A journalist at the tabloid The Daily News also compared the crimes, pointing out the striking similarities between the women's living circumstances, their missing purses, and how their killers hadn't left a trace. But investigators firmly believed Penina had been killed by her boyfriend and that Jillian was attacked by a stranger. Police looked into known sex offenders
她的钱包在公寓里不见了，表明凶手偷走了它。观察吉莉安和佩妮娜尸体的病理学家注意到她们伤口之间的相似之处。两人都是在床上睡觉时被多次刺伤。小报《每日新闻》的一名记者也比较了这些罪行，指出了这些女性的生活环境、她们丢失的钱包以及凶手如何没有留下痕迹之间的惊人相似之处。但调查人员坚信佩妮娜是被她的男友杀害的，而吉莉安是被一个陌生人袭击的。警方调查了已知的性犯罪者
in the area as the injuries to Jillian's breasts and groin appeared to indicate a sexual motivation. It would turn out that over the past 11 months there had been eight reports of a prowler lurking around the Brookwood flat. Someone had broken into apartments there and taken money, alcohol, and keys. One time a car was stolen. A number of these reports were made by Jillian's mother, Betty, who lived in the flat next door to her daughter. Her first report came just three weeks after Penina Berkman's murder in January at the start of the year. If the murder of Penina Berkman shocked Perth months earlier, this second slaying left it reeling. Not only was it another brutal killing in a city that saw few crimes of that nature, but Gillian Brewer's wealth and social status elevated the
在该地区，因为吉莉安乳房和腹股沟的伤口似乎表明有性动机。事实证明，在过去的11个月里，有八起关于徘徊者潜伏在布鲁克伍德公寓周围的报告。有人闯入那里的公寓并拿走了钱、酒精和钥匙。有一次一辆车被偷了。其中一些报告是由住在她女儿隔壁公寓的吉莉安的母亲贝蒂提出的。她的第一份报告是在年初1月份佩妮娜·伯克曼谋杀案发生仅三周后提出的。如果说几个月前佩妮娜·伯克曼的谋杀案震惊了珀斯，那么这第二起杀戮让它陷入了混乱。这不仅是这个犯罪率极低的城市中又一起残酷的杀戮，而且吉莉安·布鲁尔的财富和社会地位将
public's horror to new heights. Gillian had lived in Coddersloe, one of the affluent western suburbs that felt cushioned from Panina's murder. Residents who also lived in Perth's comfortable western enclave could relate to Jillian. She was one of us, a community member later told filmmakers of the 2020 documentary series, After the Night. As well as dominating the news cycle, Jillian's murder became the focus of many local conversations. The Brookwood flats where she'd lived and died were now a public spectacle, with parents driving their children past the building so they could stare at it through the car windows. Even through their fear and anxiety, most Perth residents felt assured that police would soon catch the person responsible. They trusted law enforcement to complete a thorough investigation
公众的恐惧提升到了新的高度。吉莉安住在科特斯洛，这是富裕的西郊之一，感觉与佩妮娜的谋杀案隔绝。同样住在珀斯舒适西部的居民也能与吉莉安产生共鸣。“她是我们的一员，”一位社区成员后来告诉2020年纪录片系列《夜幕之后》的制片人。除了占据新闻周期外，吉莉安的谋杀案也成为许多当地谈话的焦点。她生活和死亡的布鲁克伍德公寓现在成了公众奇观，父母们开车带着孩子经过这栋建筑，这样他们就可以透过车窗盯着它看。即使在恐惧和焦虑中，大多数珀斯居民也感到确信警方很快就会抓住凶手。他们相信执法部门会进行彻底的调查
and keep the public safe. Despite their faith, weeks and then months passed with no arrest in the case. with no arrest in the case. Casefile will be back shortly. Thank you for supporting us by listening to this episode's sponsors. Thank you for listening to this episode's ads. By supporting our sponsors, you support Casefile to continue to deliver quality content. 1960 dawned and Perth welcomed another new year. The city had continued to grow both in size and population. Also on the increase was the number of break-ins and prowler encounters being reported to the police. Sometimes cars were stolen from driveways and
并确保公众安全。尽管他们有信心，但几周甚至几个月过去了，案件仍未破获。Casefile很快就会回来。感谢您通过收听本集节目的赞助商来支持我们。感谢您收听本集节目的广告。通过支持我们的赞助商，您支持Casefile继续提供高质量的内容。1960年黎明，珀斯迎来了又一个新年。这座城市在规模和人口上继续增长。向警方报告的入室盗窃和徘徊者遭遇的数量也在增加。有时汽车会从车道和
garages. These were later found either abandoned somewhere else in the city or returned with a slightly emptier petrol tank. Neighbourhoods all over Perth were being targeted, from south of the river suburbs like Como and South Perth to those just north and west of the city. These crimes continued over the following years. Sometimes the same target was hit twice. In March 1961, a tin of silver coins was stolen from a residence in Swanbourne, close to Cottesloe Beach. Two weeks later, a 24-year-old woman inside the same home was attacked by an intruder after she heard him break in. As she tried to phone for help, the intruder grabbed her by the throat and wrestled her to the floor. She briefly lost consciousness, then came to and managed to kick the man in the groin. He fled out the back door and the woman ran to the window to watch him go. Under the sharp
车库被偷。这些车后来要么在城市的其他地方被发现遗弃，要么被归还时油箱稍微空了一些。珀斯各地的社区都成为了目标，从河以南的科莫和南珀斯等郊区，到城市以北和以西的郊区。这些罪行在随后的几年里持续发生。有时同一个目标会被袭击两次。1961年3月，一罐银币从斯旺伯恩的一处住宅被盗，靠近科特斯洛海滩。两周后，同一家中的一名24岁女性在听到入侵者闯入后遭到了袭击。当她试图打电话求救时，入侵者抓住她的喉咙并将她摔倒在地。她短暂地失去了知觉，然后醒来并设法踢了那个男人的腹股沟。他从后门逃走，女人跑到窗边看着他离开。在明亮的
glow of the streetlights, she saw that he was white, between 5 foot 6 and 5 foot 8, and well built. His face was broad and clean shaven, and he had dark, wavy hair. On another occasion in 1962, a woman was cleaning up after a party her teenage daughter had held at their Cotterslow home. As she did so, she noticed a man outside the house watching her. He was lurking behind a bush wearing a large brimmed hat. The woman told her husband who chased after the man, but lost him in the darkness. him in the darkness. On Saturday March 3 1962, a 23-year-old named Anne Melvin was feeling nervous. She'd moved out of her childhood home just a few weeks earlier and was now sharing a flat with her sister in the western suburb of Crawley.
路灯光下，她看到他是一个白人，身高在5英尺6英寸到5英尺8英寸之间，身材魁梧。他的脸很宽，刮得很干净，留着深色的波浪发。1962年的另一次事件中，一位女性正在清理她十几岁的女儿在科特斯洛家中举办派对后的现场。当她这样做时，她注意到房子外面有一个男人在看着她。他潜伏在灌木丛后面，戴着一顶宽边帽。这位女性告诉了她的丈夫，丈夫追赶那个男人，但在黑暗中跟丢了。1962年3月3日星期六，一位名叫安妮·梅尔文的23岁女性感到紧张。她几周前刚搬出童年的家，现在和她的姐姐住在西郊的克劳利。
Anne's sister was out that night and it would be the first time Anne had stayed in the western suburb of Crawley. Anne's sister was out that night and it would be the first time Anne had stayed in the flat alone. She made herself a snack and was having a coffee when she heard a noise on the porch outside. Anne paused and listened carefully. When she didn't hear anything else she told herself it must have been a cat. Anne went to bed and slept peacefully for a little while, before she suddenly started having an awful nightmare. In the dream, she was suffocating. Anne forced herself awake only to realise that she wasn't just dreaming. A piece of towling was wrapped tightly around her neck. Her left arm had been tied to the bedhead with a stocking, and most terrifying of all, there was a man standing next to her bed removing his belt.
安妮的姐姐那天晚上出去了，这将是安妮第一次独自待在公寓里。她给自己做了点零食，正在喝咖啡时，听到外面门廊上有动静。安妮停下来仔细听。当她没有听到其他声音时，她告诉自己那一定是一只猫。安妮上床睡觉，平静地睡了一会儿，然后突然开始做一场可怕的噩梦。在梦中，她快要窒息了。安妮强迫自己醒来，却意识到她不仅仅是在做梦。一块毛巾紧紧地缠在她的脖子上。她的左臂被一根长筒袜绑在床头上，最可怕的是，床边站着一个男人，正在解他的皮带。
Anne sat up, tore desperately at the towling at her neck, and began to scream. tore desperately at the tolling at her neck and began to scream. At the sound of her yells, the man ran out of the room. Anne managed to free her arm and took off after him, screaming that she was going to kill him. In her terror and confusion, she had forgotten that her sister was away for the evening, and when Anne saw her empty bed, she believed the intruder must have kidnapped her. The man got away, but Anne's screams attracted the attention of some nearby neighbours, who found her on her balcony with blood dribbling from her mouth. One of the neighbours comforted Anne, while the other called the police. comforted Anne while the other called the police. A detective who soon arrived was shocked to see Anne's appearance. She looked as though she was almost dead, with bloodshot eyes and raw,
安妮坐起来，拼命撕扯脖子上的毛巾，开始尖叫。听到她的叫声，那个男人跑出了房间。安妮设法挣脱了手臂，追了出去，尖叫着说她要杀了他。在恐惧和混乱中，她忘记了姐姐那天晚上不在家，当安妮看到她空荡荡的床时，她认为入侵者一定绑架了她。那个男人逃脱了，但安妮的尖叫声引起了附近一些邻居的注意，他们在阳台上发现了她，她的嘴里流着血。其中一位邻居安慰安妮，而另一位则报了警。一位很快赶到的侦探看到安妮的样子感到震惊。她看起来几乎要死了，眼睛充血，脖子和手腕上有生硬的
red markings on her neck and wrist. Anne moved back in with her parents after the attack and would only leave the house to go to church. Terrified her attacker would track her down, she eventually left Australia altogether. A few days after the attack against Anne Melvin, the couple who had come to her rescue woke to find their car covered in pairs of women's underpants. They had been twisted around door handles, tucked under the windscreen wipers and stuck into any available gaps. The couple notified the police who attended the property and found footprints in the garden beds. Some of the plants were trampled. It appeared as though someone had been lurking in the area, looking through the windows. In the months that followed, there were more reports of a
红色痕迹。袭击发生后，安妮搬回了父母家，只有去教堂时才会离开房子。由于害怕袭击者会追踪到她，她最终完全离开了澳大利亚。在针对安妮·梅尔文的袭击发生几天后，那对前来营救她的夫妇醒来发现他们的车上覆盖着成对的女性内裤。它们被缠在门把手上，塞在挡风玻璃雨刷下，并塞进了任何可用的缝隙里。这对夫妇通知了警方，警方赶到现场并在花园里发现了脚印。一些植物被踩坏了。看起来好像有人一直潜伏在该地区，透过窗户窥视。在随后的几个月里，有更多关于
prowler around Perth. On one occasion on Saturday December 29 1962, a woman in Codderslow woke to find a man in her room. He'd wrapped a handkerchief around his face as a disguise and was shining a torch in her eyes. The man punched her face before fleeing. Later that same night, another young woman in coderslow was woken by the same prowler. In addition to the handkerchief, he wore a hat and had leather gloves on his hands as well as what looked like a knuckle duster. He hit her over the head with the torch before punching above her eye. The woman screamed which woke her parents as well as some neighbours. By the time her parents reached her bedroom, the attacker had
珀斯周围徘徊者的报告。1962年12月29日星期六，科特斯洛的一名女性醒来发现房间里有一个男人。他用手帕蒙住脸作为伪装，并用手电筒照着她的眼睛。那个男人打了她的脸，然后逃跑了。当天晚上晚些时候，科特斯洛的另一名年轻女性被同一个徘徊者惊醒。除了手帕，他还戴着帽子，手上戴着皮手套，还有看起来像指节套的东西。他用手电筒击打她的头部，然后打了她的眼睛上方。这位女性尖叫起来，惊醒了她的父母以及一些邻居。当她的父母到达她的卧室时，袭击者已经
fled. It would later turn out that he had stolen cash from the young woman's purse. An internal police report on this latter attack noticed that over the past six months there had been a pattern of break-in enters at homes in the area. Whoever was behind the break-ins was entering via unlocked doors and open windows. The offender would steal cash and his crimes appeared to be escalating. Quote, Of late, these reports have become more frequent and some concern is being felt for the safety of women who are being disturbed by the offender after he has entered the premises and stolen what money he can find.
逃跑了。后来发现他从那个年轻女性的钱包里偷了现金。一份关于后一次袭击的内部警察报告注意到，在过去的六个月里，该地区的住宅入室盗窃案呈现出一种模式。无论谁是这些入室盗窃案的幕后黑手，都是通过未锁的门和打开的窗户进入的。罪犯会偷走现金，他的罪行似乎在升级。引文：“近来，这些报告变得更加频繁，人们对女性的安全感到担忧，她们在罪犯进入场所并偷走他能找到的钱后受到骚扰。”
One witness who saw the offender fleeing described him as being aged between 30 and 40 with a tan complexion. His height was short at around 5 foot 9 and he had a thin to medium build. The offender wore a suit as well as a black felt hat with a wide brim and close fitting white gloves. Sometimes his face was masked. He never left fingerprints behind and he never spoke. never left fingerprints behind and he never spoke. The report was distributed to police patrols who were asked to be aware of the situation and told it was crucial that the offender be apprehended before his crimes escalated further. Perth's police had no idea just how far his crimes had already gone. just how far his crimes had already gone. In early 1963, Perth was experiencing another hot summer. On Friday February 15, in the inner
一名目击罪犯逃跑的证人描述他年龄在30到40岁之间，肤色黝黑。他个子不高，大约5英尺9英寸，身材中等。罪犯穿着西装，戴着一顶黑色宽边毡帽和紧身白手套。有时他的脸被遮住。他从不留下指纹，也从不说话。这份报告分发给了警察巡逻队，他们被要求注意这种情况，并被告知在罪犯罪行进一步升级之前将其逮捕至关重要。珀斯警方根本不知道他的罪行已经达到了什么程度。1963年初，珀斯正在经历另一个炎热的夏天。2月15日星期五，在内
city suburb of West Perth, two young women were busy polishing the floors of a flat they'd recently rented together. 24-year-old Constance Madrill, who went by her middle name Lucy, was a government-employed social worker. Her housemate, Jennifer Hurst, worked as a school teacher. The two friends were happy with their new home, a two-bedroom flat inside a large house that had been converted into two apartments. Although the area had had issues with prowlers and break-ins, the property was situated on a busy road which made them feel safe. Plus, a family of three rented the other flat, so there was always someone nearby. Lucy felt secure enough there that she kept the back door propped open at all times so that her Siamese cat could come and go. After the two women finished polishing the floors,
城郊区西珀斯，两名年轻女性正忙着擦拭她们最近合租的一间公寓的地板。24岁的康斯坦斯·马德里尔（使用中间名露西）是一名政府雇用的社会工作者。她的室友詹妮弗·赫斯特是一名学校教师。两个朋友对她们的新家很满意，这是一间位于一栋被改造成两间公寓的大房子里的两居室公寓。虽然该地区一直有徘徊者和入室盗窃的问题，但该房产位于一条繁忙的道路上，这让她们感到安全。此外，一家三口租了另一间公寓，所以附近总有人。露西觉得在那里足够安全，所以她一直把后门敞开，以便她的暹罗猫可以自由进出。两名女性擦完地板后，
they each retired to separate rooms to read for the rest of the night. Between 11 and 11.30pm, Lucy stopped by Jennifer's bedroom to say good night, now wearing a short blue nightie. She then headed to her own room at the other end of the flat near the back door. At around 1.30am, Jennifer got up to go to the toilet which was at the rear of the property. got up to go to the toilet which was at the rear of the property. On her way back to bed, she looked in on Lucy's room. Lucy was asleep on her bed, having pulled aside the top sheet and blanket due to the warm night. Jennifer returned to her room and wasn't disturbed for the rest of the night. Across a lane at the rear of Lucy and Jennifer's flat was a house with a large lawn out the back. At 6am the morning of Saturday February 16, one of the house's residents got up with her young son and the two went to use the outhouse
他们各自回到不同的房间，在当晚剩下的时间里看书。晚上11点到11点半之间，露西顺道去詹妮弗的卧室道晚安，当时她穿着一件短款蓝色睡裙。随后，她前往位于公寓另一端、靠近后门的自己房间。凌晨1点半左右，詹妮弗起床去位于房产后方的厕所。在她回卧室的路上，她探头看了看露西的房间。露西在床上睡着了，因为当晚天气炎热，她掀开了床单和毯子。詹妮弗回到自己的房间，当晚余下的时间里没有受到任何干扰。在露西和詹妮弗公寓后方的小巷对面，有一栋房子，屋后有一个大草坪。2月16日星期六早上6点，这户人家的一名住户带着她年幼的儿子起床，两人去使用户外厕所。
that sat at the back of the property. Their attention was drawn to a strange bundle that appeared to be lying on the ground near a hill's hoist washing line. The woman walked closer and realised that she was looking at the naked body of a young woman. The body belonged to 24-year-old Lucy Madrill. An empty whiskey bottle was tucked into the crook of her right arm. Police found out that the couple who lived at the house had sat outside the previous night drinking the whiskey together. When they retired to bed at around midnight, one of them had tossed the empty bottle onto the lawn. Lucy's killer had seemingly found it while dumping her body and used it to penetrate her before posing it under her arm. Lucy's blue nightie lay alongside her.
那间厕所位于房产后方。他们的注意力被一个奇怪的包裹吸引了，它似乎躺在山坡晾衣架附近的地上。那名女子走近一看，意识到自己看到的是一具年轻女性的赤裸尸体。这具尸体属于24岁的露西·马德里尔。她的右臂弯里夹着一个空威士忌酒瓶。警方发现，住在那栋房子里的那对夫妇前一天晚上曾坐在外面一起喝威士忌。当他们在午夜左右上床睡觉时，其中一人把空瓶子扔到了草坪上。露西的凶手似乎在抛尸时发现了它，并用它侵犯了她，然后将其摆放在她的手臂下。露西的蓝色睡裙躺在她身边。
There was a blue bruise across her neck and she had been strangled with a ligature, such as a cord. The killer had raped Lucy post-mortem. The killer had initially dragged Lucy from her home with her heels trailing along the ground before reversing his approach and pulling her across the lawn by her legs. Lucy's bedroom hadn't been ransacked. Her clothes from the day before were lying on the floor near a wall, likely where she'd left them after undressing. Her sheet and blanket were turned back and a dressing gown lay across the foot of her bed. Detectives identified what had likely been the murder weapon. A piece of flax had been torn from a reading lamp in another room. One pound had been stolen from a
她的脖子上有一块蓝色淤青，她是被人用绳索之类的东西勒死的。凶手在露西死后对她进行了强奸。凶手最初将露西从家中拖出，她的脚后跟在地上拖行，随后他改变了方式，抓着她的双腿将她拖过草坪。露西的卧室没有被翻乱。她前一天的衣服躺在墙边的地板上，很可能是她脱下衣服后留在那里的。她的床单和毯子被掀开了，一件晨衣横在床尾。侦探们确定了很可能是凶器的东西。一根亚麻绳从另一个房间的台灯上被扯了下来。有一个钱包里的一英镑被偷了。
purse. The murder of Lucy Madrill called to mind the murders of Panina Berkman and Gillian Brewer several years earlier. Although those cases involved stabbing, not strangulation, there was a familiar element in that all involved a young woman brutalised in her own home and left in a state of undress. Lucy's case was almost more shocking due to the horrific way that her body had been violated, then posed out in the open. Over the past five years, the increase in break-ins and attacks against women at home had made Perth residents far more vigilant about locking doors than they ever had before. The murder of Lucy Madrill amplified their wariness. Yet reports continued to trickle through about nighttime break-ins and prowling incidents across the city. In suburbs throughout
露西·马德里尔的谋杀案让人想起了几年前帕尼娜·伯克曼和吉莉安·布鲁尔的谋杀案。虽然那些案件涉及刺伤而非勒死，但有一个共同点，那就是所有案件都涉及一名年轻女性在自己家中遭到残忍对待，并被弃置在衣不蔽体的状态下。露西的案件更令人震惊，因为她的尸体被亵渎并被摆放在空旷处的方式极其恐怖。在过去的五年里，入室盗窃和针对女性的袭击事件的增加，使得珀斯居民比以往任何时候都更加警惕锁门。露西·马德里尔的谋杀案加剧了他们的戒心。然而，关于全市夜间入室盗窃和徘徊事件的报告仍不断传来。在珀斯北、南、西部的郊区，
the north, south, and west of Perth, residents found they were missing cash. Typically, the burglaries weren't discovered until the thief was long gone, but sometimes he was caught in the act. On one occasion, a couple kissing good night in Como spotted a man hiding in the bushes watching them. Another time at a house in Applecross, a little girl went into her kitchen and spotted the silhouette of a man. Is that you, daddy? she asked as he darted out the back door. In one encounter, a man came across the prowler in his home. He begged the homeowner to let him go, claiming he was only there because he was unemployed and desperate to feed his children.
居民们发现他们丢失了现金。通常情况下，盗窃案直到小偷离开很久后才被发现，但有时他会被当场抓获。有一次，一对在科莫亲吻道晚安的情侣发现一个男人躲在灌木丛中看着他们。另一次在阿普尔克罗斯的一所房子里，一个小女孩走进厨房，看到了一个男人的剪影。“是你吗，爸爸？”她问道，这时他冲出了后门。在一次遭遇中，一名男子在自己家中撞见了那个徘徊者。他恳求房主放他走，声称他之所以在那里是因为他失业了，急于养活自己的孩子。
Taking pity on who he thought was a desperate burglar, the man gave him some food and let him leave. One afternoon at 5pm, a woman named Phyllis was in her South Perth kitchen preparing dinner when a strange man walked in. He had dark hair underneath his brimmed hat, was short, and carried a leather suitcase. The man's most notable feature was his cleft lip and palate, a relatively common birth defect in which there is a split in an individual's upper lip. As the man calmly strolled in, he turned and looked blankly at one of Phyllis's sons who was playing nearby. Then he put his bag down and started questioning Phyllis, first asking if her husband was home. Phyllis said yes, he was sitting in the lounge room.
那名男子同情他，以为他是一个绝望的窃贼，便给了他一些食物并让他离开了。一天下午5点，一位名叫菲利斯的女士正在她南珀斯的厨房里准备晚餐，这时一个陌生的男人走了进来。他戴着一顶宽边帽，帽子下是深色的头发，个子不高，提着一个皮箱。这个男人最显著的特征是他的唇腭裂，这是一种相对常见的出生缺陷，即人的上唇有裂缝。当这个男人平静地走进来时，他转过头，面无表情地看着菲利斯的一个正在附近玩耍的儿子。然后他放下包，开始盘问菲利斯，先是问她丈夫是否在家。菲利斯说是的，他正坐在客厅里。
Phyllis said yes, he was sitting in the lounge room. The man asked how many children the couple had, how old they were, and which schools they attended. Phyllis was terrified, but something told her that the best way to handle the situation was by remaining calm and unfazed. She politely answered his questions. When she finished, the man picked up his bag again, turned, and walked out of the house. Phyllis rushed to her husband to tell him what had happened and the couple ran to a window. The man was outside, casually walking down the street and disappearing around the corner like nothing unusual had happened. Halfway through the year on Saturday June 15 1963, 20-year-old Carmel Reed was going to a party. Carmel did clerical and statistical work at the University of Western Australia and didn't have many late nights out. But tonight was a special occasion. It was the 21st birthday
菲利斯说是的，他正坐在客厅里。那个男人问这对夫妇有几个孩子，他们多大了，上哪所学校。菲利斯吓坏了，但直觉告诉她，处理这种情况的最好方法是保持冷静和镇定。她礼貌地回答了他的问题。当她说完后，那个男人又拿起他的包，转身走出了房子。菲利斯冲向她丈夫告诉他发生了什么事，两人跑到窗边。那个男人在外面，若无其事地走在街上，转过拐角消失了，就像什么异常的事情都没发生过一样。年中，1963年6月15日星期六，20岁的卡梅尔·里德要去参加一个聚会。卡梅尔在西澳大利亚大学从事文书和统计工作，很少有深夜外出的情况。但今晚是一个特殊的场合。这是她最亲密的朋友之一的21岁生日。
of one of her closest friends. Carmel had a fun night and was driven home at 2.20am by her friend's fiance, who made sure she got into her home safely. Carmel had moved into her flat in Netherlands just one month earlier and was living there with two other young women. One of them, who Carmel shared a room with, was staying with her boyfriend that night, while the other housemate was already fast asleep by the time Carmel got home. Carmel got ready for bed and checked all of the windows and doors were locked. There was just one window she didn't check. It was a small ventilator window located about five feet up the lounge room wall. As it only measured two feet by one and a half feet, Carmel figured it was safe to leave slightly open.
卡梅尔度过了一个愉快的夜晚，凌晨2点20分由她朋友的未婚夫开车送回家，他确保她安全进入了家中。卡梅尔一个月前刚搬进她在内德兰兹的公寓，和另外两名年轻女性住在一起。其中一个与卡梅尔合住一个房间的人那天晚上和她的男朋友待在一起，而另一个室友在卡梅尔回家时已经熟睡了。卡梅尔准备睡觉，检查了所有的窗户和门是否锁好。只有一个窗户她没检查。那是一个位于客厅墙上约五英尺高的小通风窗。因为它只有两英尺乘一英尺半大，卡梅尔觉得稍微开着应该是安全的。
She climbed into bed at 2.45. Two hours later she was abruptly awoken by a rustling sound coming from the dining room. Carmel's heart started to pound and she called out, is anyone there? No reply came and the noise stopped. Carmel sat up in bed, listening carefully. Then she saw the figure of a man appear in her doorway. He shone a bright torch into her eyes, blinding her as he walked into the room. Carmel hid under her bedsheets and screamed. In response, the man stubbed at her chest with a sharp object. Carmel's chest seared with pain and she rolled away to escape the barrage.
她在2点45分爬上床。两个小时后，她被餐厅传来的一阵沙沙声惊醒。卡梅尔的心开始狂跳，她喊道：“有人吗？”没有回应，噪音停止了。卡梅尔坐在床上，仔细聆听。然后她看到一个男人的身影出现在她的门口。他用强光手电筒照向她的眼睛，在她走进房间时让她目眩。卡梅尔躲在床单下尖叫起来。作为回应，那个男人用尖锐的物体刺向她的胸口。卡梅尔的胸口一阵剧痛，她翻身躲避攻击。
She realised she needed to try to escape. Carmel flung off her sheet and blanket, hoping to hit the man with them, then leapt out of bed and bolted for the door. It was dark and she couldn't see anything. Suddenly she felt a sharp, stinging sensation in her face. The man had hit her. Then he fled from the flat, dropping the object he'd stabbed Carmel with as he went. It was an umbrella he'd found in her room and he'd used it still point to jab at her. Screaming, Carmel ran to her housemate's room and found her cowering in bed, having overheard the attack. Neighbours who heard the commotion called the police. Officers quickly descended on the flat, but recovered nothing belonging to
她意识到自己必须尝试逃跑。卡梅尔甩掉床单和毯子，希望能用它们击中那个男人，然后跳下床，冲向门口。天很黑，她什么也看不见。突然，她感到脸上有一种尖锐的刺痛感。那个男人打了她。然后他逃离了公寓，在离开时丢下了他刺伤卡梅尔的物体。那是一把她在房间里发现的雨伞，他一直用伞尖戳她。卡梅尔尖叫着跑向室友的房间，发现她蜷缩在床上，因为听到了袭击声。听到骚乱的邻居报了警。警察迅速赶到公寓，但没有找到属于
the intruder, not even any fingerprints. The only thing taken from the property was a purse that contained 15 shillings. It would turn out that one of the extra police cars patrolling the area due to the frequency of these attacks had passed by Carmel's apartment building just minutes before the assault. The Prowler break-ins weren't the only reason for police issuing additional patrols throughout the relatively small city. There had been a number of other crimes that had warranted the extra manpower, but no one in law enforcement realised that they were actually all connected. Almost five years earlier, on the night of Friday September 12 1958, a woman named Nell Schneider had been riding her bike home in the southern suburb of Bentley, about eight kilometres
入侵者的任何东西，甚至连指纹都没有。从房产中拿走的唯一东西是一个装有15先令的钱包。事实证明，由于这些袭击的频率，在附近巡逻的额外警车之一在袭击发生前几分钟刚刚经过卡梅尔的公寓大楼。徘徊者的入室盗窃并不是警方在整个相对较小的城市增加巡逻的唯一原因。还有许多其他犯罪行为需要额外的人力，但执法部门没有人意识到它们实际上都是相互关联的。大约五年前，1958年9月12日星期五晚上，一位名叫内尔·施耐德的女士在南部郊区本特利骑自行车回家，距离
from Perth's CBD. When she was just a few hundred metres from her home, a car suddenly sped up behind her and slammed into her bicycle. The bike became stuck to the car's grille as Nell was thrown up in the air. She slammed down on the road head first. As quickly as it had arrived, the car sped away, disappearing into the night. Nell was left lying on the bitumen, unconscious in a pool of blood. She was found by a passing motorist about 45 minutes later and remained in a coma for two weeks. Although she eventually recovered, Nell was diagnosed with chronic post-traumatic temporal lobe epilepsy, which led to her experiencing blackouts and seizures on occasion. The car used in the attack was identified as a Ford Consul, which had been stolen that same
珀斯中央商务区约八公里。当她距离家只有几百米时，一辆汽车突然在她身后加速，撞上了她的自行车。自行车卡在了汽车的格栅上，内尔被抛向空中。她头朝下重重地摔在路上。汽车像来时一样快地加速离开，消失在夜色中。内尔躺在沥青路上，昏迷不醒，血流如注。大约45分钟后，她被一名路过的司机发现，并陷入昏迷长达两周。虽然她最终康复了，但内尔被诊断出患有慢性创伤后颞叶癫痫，这导致她偶尔会出现昏厥和癫痫发作。袭击中使用的汽车被确认为一辆福特领事，它是同一天晚上从维多利亚公园的一户人家偷来的。
night from a home in Victoria Park. It was found abandoned about half a mile from where Nell was struck. No fingerprints were recovered from the vehicle. Police attributed the theft of the car to joyriders and concluded that they had most likely hit Nell by accident while speeding, then flared in panic. The incident featured in some newspaper headlines and officers began an intensive search for the culprits. The investigations continued for some time, but with nothing more to go on, they made no progress. What the police didn't know was that the man who would later be dubbed the Night Caller had abruptly started committing a new kind of attack. He'd been breaking into residences and prowling
它被发现遗弃在距离内尔被撞地点约半英里处。车内没有发现指纹。警方将这辆车的盗窃归咎于飙车族，并断定他们很可能是在超速行驶时意外撞到了内尔，然后惊慌失措地逃跑了。这一事件出现在一些报纸的头条上，警察开始对肇事者进行深入搜查。调查持续了一段时间，但由于没有更多线索，他们没有取得任何进展。警方不知道的是，那个后来被称为“夜间来电者”的男人已经突然开始实施一种新的袭击。他多年来一直在闯入住宅并徘徊，
for years, but this was his first violent assault against a stranger. Three and a half months later, on Saturday December 27, a woman named Cathy Bellis was walking home from a bus stop late at night after working a shift as a waitress. Cathy lived in Belmont, then a new suburb in the city's east. There were no street lights there in 1958, so Cathy pulled out a small torch she kept for occasions when she had to walk their suburbs' unlit streets at night. Shining it in front of her, she began to make her way home. It was only two blocks, but Cathy's surroundings were pitch black and very isolated. The street she walked along had no houses, just paddocks and bushland
但这还是他第一次对陌生人进行暴力袭击。三个半月后，12月27日星期六，一位名叫凯西·贝利斯的女士在深夜做完服务员的工作后，正从公交车站步行回家。凯西住在贝尔蒙特，那是当时城市东部的一个新郊区。1958年那里没有路灯，所以凯西拿出了一个小手电筒，以备晚上必须走郊区未照明的街道时使用。她照着前方，开始往家走。只有两个街区，但凯西周围漆黑一片，非常偏僻。她走的那条街没有房子，只有围场和灌木丛
flanking the bitumen road that had only been recently built. Suddenly, a car sped up behind Cathy, engine revving. It veered straight towards her, striking Cathy hard and throwing her sixty feet across an intersection and into a neighbouring paddock. As Cathy lay in the soft ground of the paddock, she drifted in and out of consciousness. Her pelvis and one of her legs seared with pain. Then she saw the face of a man looming above her. Realising it was the car's driver, but unsure whether or not she was hallucinating, she begged, don't leave me or I'll die. The man laughed, then ran back to his car and sped away. Kathy was discovered by a couple who'd heard her anguished cries and was rushed to the hospital.
环绕着那条刚修好的沥青路。突然，一辆汽车在凯西身后加速，引擎轰鸣。它径直向她冲来，猛烈地撞击凯西，将她抛出六十英尺远，穿过一个十字路口，落入邻近的围场。当凯西躺在围场柔软的地面上时，她处于半昏迷状态。她的骨盆和一条腿一阵剧痛。然后她看到了一个男人的脸笼罩在她上方。意识到那是肇事司机，但不确定自己是否在产生幻觉，她恳求道：“别丢下我，否则我会死的。”那个男人笑了笑，然后跑回他的车，加速离开了。凯西被一对听到她痛苦呼喊的夫妇发现，并被紧急送往医院。
She had suffered a broken pelvis, two breaks in her leg, a shattered knee, a fracture to the base of her spine, and another fracture at the top of her skull. Over the next year, Cathy had to undergo multiple surgeries and treatments. She would never be able to run again. The car that had struck her turned out to be a ute that was stolen the previous night from the suburb of Como, 9 kilometres southwest of Belmont. It was subsequently dumped about 5 kilometres away from the crime scene. More than a year went by with no more mysterious hidden runs, but plenty of other, seemingly unrelated crimes were committed during that time, including the murders of Panina Berkman and Jillian
她的骨盆骨折，腿部两处骨折，膝盖粉碎，脊柱底部骨折，头骨顶部还有另一处骨折。在接下来的一年里，凯西不得不接受多次手术和治疗。她再也无法奔跑了。撞倒她的那辆车原来是一辆皮卡，是前一天晚上从距离贝尔蒙特西南9公里的科莫郊区偷来的。它随后被丢弃在距离犯罪现场约5公里处。一年多过去了，没有再发生神秘的肇事逃逸事件，但在那段时间里，发生了许多其他看似无关的犯罪，包括帕尼娜·伯克曼和吉莉安·布鲁尔的谋杀案。
Brewer. Then, almost four months after Jillian's murder, the hidden runs started again. Casefile will be back shortly. Thank you for supporting us by listening to this episode's sponsors. by listening to this episode's sponsors. Thank you for listening to this episode's ads. By supporting our sponsors, you support Casefile to continue to deliver quality content. On Saturday, April 9, 1960, a 20-year-old named Glenis Peake walked home from a night out at a dance. An almost full moon illuminated the night sky as Glenis walked alone in the suburb of Bayswater,
然后，在吉莉安被谋杀近四个月后，肇事逃逸事件再次开始。Casefile稍后回来。感谢您通过收听本集赞助商的节目来支持我们。感谢您收听本集的广告。通过支持我们的赞助商，您支持Casefile继续提供优质内容。1960年4月9日星期六，一名叫格莱尼斯·皮克的20岁女孩从一场舞会回家。当格莱尼斯独自走在贝斯沃特郊区时，一轮近乎满月的月亮照亮了夜空，
six kilometres northeast of Perth CBD. Glenis kept to the right side of the road so she would be facing any oncoming traffic. It was after midnight and the streets were quiet. This area of Perth was sparsely populated with few houses and residents. Shortly into her walk, the headlights of a car appeared behind her. As it passed, Glenis took note of the make, a Holden sedan with a short-looking man behind the wheel. The car kept driving and made a right turn further up the road, vanishing into the darkness. Glenis kept walking. When she reached the street the car had turned into, she noticed that the Holden was parked there with the driver still inside, facing her. Glenys was mildly puzzled by this. As it happened,
距离珀斯中央商务区东北六公里。格莱尼斯保持在道路右侧，这样她就能面对任何迎面而来的车辆。当时已过午夜，街道很安静。珀斯这一地区人口稀少，房屋和居民很少。她走了一会儿，身后出现了汽车的前灯。当它经过时，格莱尼斯注意到了品牌，一辆霍顿轿车，驾驶座上是一个看起来个子不高的男人。汽车继续行驶，在前方右转，消失在黑暗中。格莱尼斯继续走。当她到达那辆车转入的街道时，她注意到那辆霍顿停在那里，司机还在里面，正对着她。格莱尼斯对此感到有些困惑。碰巧的是，
she had to go down the same street as the car to get home, only she was headed in the opposite direction. Glenys turned left onto the side street. She was just one block from her home. She walked in the middle of the street in order to see better, as the moon was no longer providing enough light and the bitumen was riddled with potholes. All of a sudden, Glenys heard the roar of an engine as a car drove up behind her. It was the same Holden as before, and it had veered into the wrong side of the road in order to head straight towards her. Glenys tried to jump out of the way, but the car hit her left hip as the driver struck Glenys from an angle so as to avoid a nearby tree. She was tossed over the bonnet, cutting her face open on one of the windscreen wipers in the process.
她必须走和那辆车同一条街才能回家，只是她走的是相反的方向。格莱尼斯左转进入侧街。她离家只有一个街区了。她走在街道中间以便看得更清楚，因为月亮不再提供足够的光线，而且沥青路上坑坑洼洼。突然，格莱尼斯听到引擎的轰鸣声，一辆车在她身后驶来。那是之前那辆霍顿，它为了径直冲向她，驶入了道路的错误一侧。格莱尼斯试图跳开，但汽车撞到了她的左臀部，司机从一个角度撞击格莱尼斯，以避开附近的一棵树。她被抛过引擎盖，在此过程中脸部被其中一个挡风玻璃雨刷割开。
Glenis landed in some gravel and a broken glass by the side of the road. She lay there, shocked but conscious, as the car drove away. She knew the driver had run her down deliberately. Terrified he'd come back to finish the job, she scrambled to her feet and stumbled home. Glenys was rushed to hospital where an assessment revealed that she hadn't broken any bones, but she had a number of wounds that required stitches. Police officers paid a visit to the scene of the hit and run. Although Glenys had said she'd left her handbag lying there, it was missing. About a hundred metres from there was a clearly abandoned car. It was a Holden sedan with the keys in the ignition. It had been stolen from the garage of
格莱尼斯落在路边的碎石和碎玻璃中。她躺在那里，震惊但清醒，看着汽车开走。她知道司机是故意撞倒她的。她害怕他会回来完成任务，于是挣扎着站起来，跌跌撞撞地跑回家。格莱尼斯被紧急送往医院，评估显示她没有骨折，但有几处伤口需要缝合。警察访问了肇事逃逸现场。虽然格莱尼斯说她把手提包留在了那里，但它不见了。距离那里大约一百米处有一辆明显被遗弃的汽车。那是一辆霍顿轿车，钥匙还在点火开关里。它是从一个二手车推销员的车库里偷来的，
a used car salesman who'd taken the Holden home from the dealership for the weekend. The attacker's fingerprints were nowhere to be found. Just after 11pm on Friday May 13, one month after Glenis Peak's hit and run, 18-year-old Jill Connell was walking home from a bus stop in Belmont when she was deliberately run down by a driver in a green Morris Minor sedan. After being thrown onto the bonnet, Jill fell to the ground, sobbing. Meanwhile, the Morris Minor had gotten stuck in some sand that bordered the road. The driver jumped out and ran away, laughing. It was an hour before Jill was found lying unconscious and bleeding behind the abandoned vehicle. She later underwent emergency surgery. The green Morris Minor had
他周末把这辆霍顿从车行开回了家。袭击者的指纹无处可寻。5月13日星期五晚上11点刚过，在格莱尼斯·皮克肇事逃逸一个月后，18岁的吉尔·康奈尔正从贝尔蒙特的一个公交车站步行回家，这时她被一辆绿色莫里斯米诺轿车的司机故意撞倒。在被抛到引擎盖上后，吉尔摔倒在地，啜泣着。与此同时，那辆莫里斯米诺卡在了路边的沙子里。司机跳出来，笑着跑开了。一个小时后，吉尔才被发现昏迷不醒、血流如注地躺在被遗弃的车辆后面。她后来接受了紧急手术。那辆绿色莫里斯米诺
been reported stolen from a home in the South Perth suburb of Como two hours earlier. The prints of the car thief weren't found anywhere on or in the vehicle. Exactly one week after the attack on Jill Connell, an 18-year-old named Georgina Pittman spent a fun night out dancing. She caught the 11.35pm train home where she struck up a conversation with 16-year-old Maureen Rogers and her 12-year-old cousin Therese Zagami, who had just attended a concert. It was raining heavily when they disembarked at Queens Park Station in South Perth and there were no taxis waiting at the cab rank outside. The only car in the vicinity was an expensive looking new Chrysler Royal which was white with a red stripe
在两小时前被报告从南珀斯科莫郊区的一户人家偷走。在车内或车外都没有发现偷车贼的指纹。在袭击吉尔·康奈尔一周后，一名叫乔治娜·皮特曼的18岁女孩度过了一个愉快的跳舞之夜。她搭乘晚上11点35分的火车回家，在那里她与16岁的莫琳·罗杰斯和她12岁的表妹特蕾莎·扎加米交谈起来，她们刚参加完一场音乐会。当她们在南珀斯的皇后公园站下车时，雨下得很大，出租车候车区外没有出租车在等候。附近唯一的一辆车是一辆看起来很昂贵的新克莱斯勒皇家，它是白色的，带有一条红色的条纹，
and had Victorian license plates. A man sat behind the wheel wearing a brimmed hat. The three girls decided to walk home. Maureen and Georgina huddled together under Maureen's umbrella while Theresa walked slightly ahead under her own umbrella. They were making their way up a George Street, an isolated road bordered by large paddocks, a few houses, and a poultry farm. Suddenly, a car zoomed past them at high speed. Gee, this guy's an idiot, Maureen said. It was the same Chrysler that had been parked at the train station. The driver then did a U-turn and sped back past the girls in the other direction before pulling into a side street behind them. The three girls kept walking. It was quiet and dark as they reached an area of the road where
挂着维多利亚州的车牌。一个戴着宽边帽的男人坐在驾驶座上。三个女孩决定步行回家。莫琳和乔治娜挤在莫琳的雨伞下，而特蕾莎撑着自己的伞走在前面一点。她们正沿着乔治街走，这是一条偏僻的道路，两旁是大围场、几栋房子和一个养鸡场。突然，一辆车高速从她们身边呼啸而过。“天哪，这家伙是个白痴，”莫琳说。正是之前停在火车站的那辆克莱斯勒。司机随后掉头，加速从女孩们身边向另一个方向驶去，然后转入她们身后的一条侧街。三个女孩继续走。当她们到达道路上的一片区域时，周围安静而黑暗，
there were no houses, only empty paddocks on either side. The still night air was abruptly broken by a roaring sound. Georgina turned around and saw headlights approaching. It was the Chrysler, veering across the road towards them. Twelve-year-old Therese, who was walking right at the road's edge, also spun around. Look out! she cried before jumping out of the car's path. It barely missed her, and Therese felt a gust of wind hit her as the vehicle passed. Then it struck Georgina and Maureen head on. Georgina was thrown into the ditch that ran alongside the road.
那里没有房子，两边只有空荡荡的围场。寂静的夜空突然被一阵轰鸣声打破。乔治娜转过身，看到前灯靠近。那是克莱斯勒，正横穿马路向她们冲来。走在路边的12岁特蕾莎也转过身来。“小心！”她喊道，然后跳出了汽车的行驶路径。它险些撞到她，当车辆经过时，特蕾莎感到一阵风吹过。然后它正面撞上了乔治娜和莫琳。乔治娜被抛进了路边的沟里。
Maureen bore the brunt of the impact as the vehicle hit her left leg and broke both of its major bones. The force of the hit had also broken the car's radiator grille. Maureen was tossed onto the bonnet and stayed there, bleeding profusely as the driver continued to speed ahead. He made a sharp turn as they reached an intersection about 100 meters up the road and Maureen finally fell from the bonnet onto the ground. Georgina Pittman was in a daze down the road looking for her shoes. She had no idea what had happened. She only knew that her feet were bare for some reason. Georgina didn't realise that her dress was also torn and she'd sustained deep cuts to her head and back which were now bleeding.
莫琳承受了撞击的冲击，车辆撞到了她的左腿，折断了它的两根主要骨头。撞击的力度也撞坏了汽车的散热器格栅。莫琳被抛到引擎盖上，并留在那里，血流如注，而司机继续加速前进。当她们到达距离路口约100米的地方时，他猛地转弯，莫琳终于从引擎盖上摔到了地上。乔治娜·皮特曼在路上神志不清地寻找她的鞋子。她根本不知道发生了什么。她只知道不知为何她的脚是赤裸的。乔治娜没有意识到她的裙子也破了，她的头部和背部受了深伤，现在正在流血。
cuts to her head and back which were now bleeding. Mum, Mum, Georgina desperately called as she walked in circles. Therese Zagami had escaped injury but was terrified that the driver would return. She began running towards home, which was up ahead in the direction they'd been walking. Therese stayed low and away from the road to hide from their attacker. As she reached the top of the hill, she came across her cousin Maureen, lying bleeding in the middle of the road. Therese ran over to her, asking, thinking, Maureen, are you alright? There was no answer. Realising her cousin must be dead, Theresa's fear intensified and she kept running towards home, which was only about another hundred metres away. Theresa's parents were out, but her aunt lived next door. Therese banged on her front door, screaming. It was deliberate. It was deliberate.
头部和背部受了深伤，现在正在流血。“妈妈，妈妈，”乔治娜一边绕着圈走，一边绝望地呼喊。特蕾莎·扎加米没有受伤，但非常害怕司机回来。她开始向家跑去，家就在她们前进方向的前方。特蕾莎保持低姿态，远离道路，以躲避袭击者。当她到达山顶时，她遇到了她的表妹莫琳，她正血流如注地躺在马路中间。特蕾莎跑过去，问着，想着：“莫琳，你还好吗？”没有回答。意识到她的表妹一定死了，特蕾莎的恐惧加剧了，她继续向家跑去，家距离那里只有大约一百米。特蕾莎的父母出去了，但她的阿姨住在隔壁。特蕾莎猛敲她的前门，尖叫着。这是故意的。这是故意的。
Just as Therese was raising the alarm, two patrol officers passing through the area stumbled across Maureen's body. She still had a pulse. They soon found Georgina as well. The girls were rushed to hospital. Maureen needed emergency surgery on her left leg. Her left cheekbone was also fractured and she was entirely covered in bruises. Georgina had a concussion and several deep gashes that needed stitches. All three girls were left with severe mental and emotional trauma. At the scene of the crime, police recovered a small piece of the car's radiator grille that had been broken during the hit and run. The Chrysler itself was found just before seven the following morning of Saturday May 21. It had been dumped near a railway line in the suburb of East Victoria Park, about five kilometres away. There was damage to the top and left side of the bonnet and the broken radiator grill matched the piece found at the scene. The Chrysler had been stolen
就在特蕾莎报警时，两名在该地区巡逻的警察偶然发现了莫琳的尸体。她还有脉搏。他们很快也找到了乔治娜。女孩们被紧急送往医院。莫琳的左腿需要紧急手术。她的左颧骨也骨折了，全身都是淤青。乔治娜脑震荡，有几处深伤口需要缝合。所有三个女孩都留下了严重的心理和情感创伤。在犯罪现场，警方找回了汽车散热器格栅的一小块碎片，它在肇事逃逸中被撞坏了。克莱斯勒本身在第二天5月21日星期六早上7点前被发现。它被丢弃在距离约五公里处的东维多利亚公园郊区的一条铁路线附近。引擎盖顶部和左侧有损坏，破碎的散热器格栅与现场发现的碎片相吻合。克莱斯勒是被偷的，
from a 60-year-old man who had driven from Melbourne to Perth to visit his adult son and his family. The family had discovered the theft the previous night and immediately reported it to the police. No fingerprints belonging to the thief were found on either the interior or exterior of the vehicle. Meanwhile, both the police and Perth's media were starting to notice the pattern of deliberate hit and runs over the past month and a half. A number of detectives and traffic police were assigned to the case, with a growing theory emerging that one man could be behind all of the crimes. Articles about the latest incident ran on the front page of the weekend papers, with
车主是一个60岁的男人，他从墨尔本开车到珀斯探望他的成年儿子和家人。这家人前一天晚上发现了盗窃案，并立即向警方报告。在车辆的内部或外部都没有发现属于小偷的指纹。与此同时，警方和珀斯的媒体都开始注意到过去一个半月里故意肇事逃逸的模式。许多侦探和交通警察被分配到此案，一个日益增长的理论浮出水面，即一个人可能是所有犯罪的幕后黑手。关于最新事件的文章登上了周末报纸的头条，
one headline asking, Is a hit-run maniac on the loose? The story read in part, quote, Three girls were apparently deliberately run down by a powerful stolen car early today. This climaxed what may be a series of cold-blooded attempts to kill all main pedestrians. Three times in the past six weeks, each time in the weekend, girls have been injured by a stolen hit-run car, later abandoned, in different suburbs. Detectives tracked down known car thieves and questioned them extensively.
一个标题问道：“一个肇事逃逸的狂人在逃吗？”故事部分写道，引用：“今天早些时候，三名女孩显然被一辆强大的被盗汽车故意撞倒。这达到了可能是冷血企图杀死所有主要行人的系列事件的高潮。在过去的六周里，三次，每次都在周末，女孩们被一辆被盗的肇事逃逸汽车伤害，后来被遗弃，在不同的郊区。”侦探们追踪了已知的偷车贼并对他们进行了广泛的审问。
Due to the hit-and-runs always taking place on a Friday or Saturday night, special patrols were implemented on those days between 5pm and 1am. In a report about the case, one detective sergeant concluded that he was convinced that one perpetrator was responsible for all three of the attacks, while acknowledging that he had no evidence. Without fingerprints or anything else belonging to the perpetrator at any of the scenes, there was no way to prove their theory. No connection was made to the Prowler breaking into homes across the city, even though he
由于肇事逃逸总是发生在周五或周六晚上，因此在这些天的下午5点到凌晨1点之间实施了特别巡逻。在一份关于此案的报告中，一名侦探警长总结说，他确信一名肇事者应对所有三次袭击负责，同时也承认他没有任何证据。由于在任何现场都没有指纹或属于肇事者的其他任何东西，因此无法证明他们的理论。没有建立起与在全市闯入民宅的“徘徊者”的联系，尽管他也
also stole cars, struck on weekend nights, targeted random victims and never left a single fingerprint. The hit and runs stopped after the attack against the Georgina Pittman, Maureen Rogers and Therese Zagami. Months passed, then years. But the night caller never ceased his crimes, and in the beginning of 1963, he would launch another shocking attack using a new kind of stolen weapon. Australia Day is Australia's official national day, observed annually on January 26. There is some controversy around this day as it was chosen to mark the landing of the first British colonists in 1788. In recent years there has been much debate as to whether it should be changed.
偷车，在周末晚上袭击，针对随机受害者，并且从未留下过一个指纹。在针对乔治娜·皮特曼、莫琳·罗杰斯和特蕾莎·扎加米的袭击之后，肇事逃逸停止了。几个月过去了，然后是几年。但“夜间来电者”从未停止他的犯罪，在1963年初，他将使用一种新的被盗武器发动另一次令人震惊的袭击。澳大利亚日是澳大利亚的官方国庆日，每年1月26日纪念。这一天存在一些争议，因为它被选为纪念1788年第一批英国殖民者登陆的日子。近年来，关于是否应该更改这一天有很多争论。
For many residents of Perth in 1963, Australia Day just signified another long weekend and a chance to enjoy the summer. The holiday fell on a Saturday that year, so Australians would have a three-day weekend with no work on Monday. Saturday January 26 was a hot night and Perth was abuzz, with many out drinking and celebrating. The Ocean Beach Hotel, a pub that sat across from the beach in North Codderslow, was packed. Bartender Rowena Reeves worked at the hotel until closing, then went to a restaurant with three friends. Afterwards, at around 2am, the group of four drove to a quiet spot overlooking the ocean to chat and have a few more drinks. However, an argument broke out between two members of the group
对于1963年珀斯的许多居民来说，澳大利亚日只是意味着又一个长周末，是一个享受夏天的机会。那年的假期恰逢星期六，所以澳大利亚人将有一个为期三天的周末，周一不用上班。1月26日星期六是一个炎热的夜晚，珀斯热闹非凡，许多人外出饮酒庆祝。海洋海滩酒店是一家位于北科特斯洛海滩对面的酒吧，里面挤满了人。酒保罗威娜·里夫斯在酒店工作到打烊，然后和三个朋友去了一家餐馆。之后，大约凌晨2点，四人组开车到一个可以俯瞰海洋的安静地方聊天，再喝几杯。然而，小组中的两名成员之间爆发了争吵，
who were a couple. They soon left, leaving Rowena alone in the car with her friend, Nick August. Rowena sat in the car's back seat, drinking pink champagne, while Nick sat behind the wheel. As Rowena sipped her drink, she noticed a man standing less than eight metres away, staring at them. She pointed him out to Nick. Nick was married and suspected the stranger had been sent by his wife to spy on him. Angered, Nick tossed an empty beer bottle at the man through the open window and yelled at him to piss off. As the bottle rolled down the street, Rowena saw the man lift up something. Look out, he's got a gun, she cried, while pushing Nick's head down so it wouldn't be visible from outside.
他们是一对情侣。他们很快离开了，留下罗威娜和她的朋友尼克·奥古斯特独自在车里。罗威娜坐在车的后座，喝着粉红香槟，而尼克坐在驾驶座上。当罗威娜啜饮她的饮料时，她注意到一个男人站在不到八米远的地方，盯着他们。她指给尼克看。尼克已婚，怀疑这个陌生人是他妻子派来监视他的。尼克很生气，通过打开的车窗向那个男人扔了一个空啤酒瓶，并对他大喊让他滚开。当瓶子滚下街道时，罗威娜看到那个男人举起了什么东西。“小心，他有枪，”她喊道，同时把尼克的头按下去，这样从外面就看不见了。
The man fired a rifle. Nick felt a sudden pain in his neck. He's got me, he stated, before hurriedly starting the car's engine and speeding away. The man with the rifle fired once again at the retreating vehicle, but missed. In the backseat of the car, Rowena was bleeding badly. The bullet that had grazed Nick's neck had then struck her wrist, shattering it. Nick sped towards the nearest hospital, which was in the port city of Fremantle, about eight kilometres south. The pair were admitted for treatment, and at 3.30am medical staff notified the police that they had two shooting victims who needed to
那个男人开了一枪。尼克感到脖子一阵剧痛。“他打中我了，”他说，然后匆忙发动汽车引擎，加速离开。那个拿着步枪的男人又向撤退的车辆开了一枪，但没打中。在车后座，罗威娜流血严重。擦过尼克脖子的子弹随后击中了她的手腕，将其击碎。尼克加速驶向最近的医院，位于南约八公里的港口城市弗里曼特尔。两人被收治接受治疗，凌晨3点30分，医务人员通知警方，他们有两名枪击受害者需要
be interviewed. It was almost half an hour later when the doorbell rang at a house on Louise Street in Netherlands, five and a half kilometres east of where Rowena Reeves and Nick August were attacked. The house was a single story brick residence home to the Warmsley family. Daughter Sandra Warmsley was woken by the doorbell which rang twice in quick succession. was woken by the doorbell which rang twice in quick succession. Sandra heard the familiar footsteps of her father, George, warmly, walking towards the front door. As he opened the door, a loud gunshot rang out. Dad, Sandra screamed, jumping out of bed and running to the front door. She was joined by her mother. To their horror, George lay in the doorway, his hair soaked with blood and his eyes glazed.
接受采访。大约半小时后，内德兰兹路易斯街的一所房子门铃响了，距离罗威娜·里夫斯和尼克·奥古斯特遇袭地点东面五点五公里。这所房子是沃姆斯利一家的单层砖房。女儿桑德拉·沃姆斯利被连续响了两次的门铃声惊醒。桑德拉听到了她父亲乔治·沃姆斯利走向前门的熟悉脚步声。当他打开门时，一声响亮的枪声响起。“爸爸，”桑德拉尖叫着，跳下床跑向前门。她的母亲也加入了进来。令她们惊恐的是，乔治躺在门口，头发被血浸透，眼睛呆滞。
Clearly visible in his forehead was a bullet hole. There was no sign of the shooter. Sandra ran to the kitchen where the family's telephone was located and called the police and a nearby neighbour. Then she returned to her father's body and tried to comfort her devastated mother. The pair were in complete shock. It made no sense that their entire world could have been turned upside down in a split second. George was a loving, warm man. It made no sense that anyone would want to harm him. Fifteen minutes later and just one block over on Vincent Street, a young man named Scott McWilliam was woken from his sleep by the sound of shouting. Scott was staying at a boarding house that was home to a number of young people and the
他的前额上清晰可见一个弹孔。没有枪手的踪迹。桑德拉跑到家里电话所在的厨房，给警察和附近的一位邻居打了电话。然后她回到父亲的尸体旁，试图安慰她悲痛欲绝的母亲。两人完全处于震惊之中。他们的整个世界在瞬间被颠覆，这毫无道理。乔治是一个充满爱心、温暖的人。没有人会想伤害他，这毫无道理。十五分钟后，在文森特街的一个街区外，一个名叫斯科特·麦克威廉的年轻人被喊叫声从睡梦中惊醒。斯科特住在一所寄宿公寓里，那里住着许多年轻人，
yelling was coming from another resident, his landlady's niece Pauline. She was saying that there was something wrong with John Sturkey, an 18-year-old boarder who was leaving Perth the following week to study veterinary medicine in Brisbane. Scott got up to see what was wrong. John had been sleeping outside on a single bed on the back veranda where the air was cooler at night. Flicking on the veranda's light switch, Scott saw there was an enormous pool of blood on the concrete flooring next to John's bed.
喊叫声来自另一位住户，他房东的侄女宝琳。她说约翰·斯图基出了问题，他是一名18岁的寄宿生，下周就要离开珀斯去布里斯班学习兽医学。斯科特起床查看出了什么问题。约翰一直睡在后阳台的一张单人床上，那里的空气在晚上更凉爽。打开阳台的电灯开关，斯科特看到约翰床边的混凝土底板上有一大滩血。
John was in the bed, with blood soaked into the linen around his head. He was making a gurgling sound. Scott and another boarder rushed forward to lift John's head up so he could breathe. There was a gunshot visible at the top of his forehead. Pauline phoned for an ambulance, then called the police. Officers told Pauline that everyone at the residence was to stay inside and keep below beneath the windows. There was somebody going around the neighbourhood shooting people. Both George Warmsley and John Sturkey were rushed in separate ambulances to Royal Perth Hospital, arriving within five minutes of one another. John was pronounced dead three minutes after arrival.
约翰躺在床上，血浸透了他头部的亚麻布。他发出咕噜声。斯科特和另一名寄宿生冲上前去抬起约翰的头，让他呼吸。他的前额顶部有一个明显的枪伤。宝琳打电话叫了救护车，然后报了警。警察告诉宝琳，住所里的每个人都要待在里面，保持在窗户下方。有人在附近到处枪杀人。乔治·沃姆斯利和约翰·斯图基都被分别送往皇家珀斯医院，两人相隔五分钟到达。约翰在到达三分钟后被宣布死亡。
George Warmsley was given emergency surgery but died about an hour and a half later. Police were still processing both crime scenes and had just been notified of the two deaths when another call came in. Len Barth wasn't initially worried when his friend Brian Weir didn't show up for a scheduled surf rescue boat training session on Sunday morning. 29-year-old Brian, whose day job was as an accountant, was often late. But after waiting around for more than two hours, Len decided to go check on Brian. He drove the short distance from the Swamborne Netherlands Surf Life Saving Club to Brian's home. Brian lived in a first-floor apartment in a block of four on Broom Street, Cottesloe. When Len arrived, he saw that the
乔治·沃姆斯利接受了紧急手术，但在大约一个半小时后死亡。警方仍在处理两个犯罪现场，刚刚接到两起死亡通知时，又接到了另一个电话。当他的朋友布莱恩·威尔没有出现在周日上午预定的冲浪救援船训练课程时，莱恩·巴斯最初并不担心。29岁的布莱恩，他的日常工作是会计师，经常迟到。但在等待了两个多小时后，莱恩决定去看看布莱恩。他从斯旺伯恩内德兰兹冲浪救生俱乐部开车前往布莱恩的家。布莱恩住在科特斯洛布鲁姆街四栋公寓楼中的一楼。当莱恩到达时，他看到
door that led from Brian's bedroom to the apartment's balcony was open. Len clambered up to the balcony and walked in. Brian was still in bed, but the scene was all wrong. His head was hanging over one side and there was blood everywhere. Brian felt stiff and his complexion was grey, but Len could still hear him faintly breathing. Len was horrified. It looked as though Brian had been in a violent fight. Len raced back to the Surf Lifesaving Club and told his teammates what he'd found. One of them had heard news reports about the overnight shootings in nearby Netherlands and they all raced back to Brian's flat together.
从布莱恩卧室通往公寓阳台的门是开着的。莱恩爬上阳台走了进去。布莱恩还在床上，但现场完全不对劲。他的头垂在一边，到处都是血。布莱恩感觉身体僵硬，脸色灰白，但莱恩仍然能听到他微弱的呼吸声。莱恩惊恐万分。看起来布莱恩经历了一场激烈的打斗。莱恩冲回冲浪救生俱乐部，告诉队友他发现了什么。其中一人听到了关于附近内德兰兹隔夜枪击事件的新闻报道，他们一起冲回了布莱恩的公寓。
When they looked more closely at their friend, they saw that the top left side of his head was completely gone. Brian was rushed to the hospital and underwent emergency surgery. A bullet was found lodged in the left temporal lobe of Brian's brain, with fragments scattered throughout. Surgeons had to remove these foreign objects, as well as splintered pieces of bone and much of Brian's damaged brain matter. Brian survived the surgery but remained in a coma. He stayed in his coma for six months with police constantly keeping guard. When Brian eventually regained consciousness he was unable to speak, walk or move his arms. His right side was entirely paralysed. He had lost sight in one eye and
当他们仔细观察朋友时，发现他头部的左上方完全消失了。布莱恩被紧急送往医院并接受了紧急手术。一颗子弹被发现卡在布莱恩大脑的左颞叶中，碎片散布在各处。外科医生不得不移除这些异物，以及破碎的骨头碎片和布莱恩大部分受损的脑组织。布莱恩在手术中幸存下来，但一直处于昏迷状态。他在昏迷中度过了六个月，期间警察一直守卫着。当布莱恩最终恢复意识时，他无法说话、行走或移动手臂。他的右侧完全瘫痪。他的一只眼睛失明，并且
hearing in one ear. The severe brain damage also caused him to have epileptic fits. Despite being just 29 years old, Brian had to be moved into an aged care nursing home due to requiring round-the-clock care. On December 19, 1965, almost three years after the attack, Brian Weir died as a result of his injuries. The Australia Day attacks dominated newspaper headlines in the immediate aftermath of the shootings. Articles provided a timeline of the attacks, which was pieced together by the police. Rowena Reeves and Nick August had been the shooter's first victims. Both had survived after sustaining injuries from the same bullet. Police had found a spent casing at the scene of the crime. The shooter had then walked around the corner and stopped outside Brian Weir's home. He'd climbed
一只耳朵失聪。严重的大脑损伤也导致他患上了癫痫。尽管布莱恩年仅29岁，但由于需要全天候护理，他不得不被送进一家养老院。1965年12月19日，即袭击发生近三年后，布莱恩·威尔因伤势过重去世。澳大利亚日袭击事件在枪击案发生后的第一时间占据了报纸头条。文章提供了由警方拼凑出的袭击时间线。罗威娜·里夫斯和尼克·奥古斯特是枪手的首批受害者。两人在被同一颗子弹击伤后幸存下来。警方在犯罪现场发现了一个弹壳。枪手随后绕过拐角，停在布莱恩·威尔家门外。他爬上了
up the first floor balcony where Brian had left the door open. Brian had dragged his bed right up to the door, sleeping with his head towards the balcony to take advantage of the sea breeze on the hot night. The shooter had shot Brian once in the head, then left the flat and headed five kilometres east to Netherlands. Once in Netherlands, the shooter walked around the back of the boarding house where John Sturkey was sleeping on the rear veranda and shot him once in the head. The shooter then walked one street over, ejecting another spent shell casing as he did so, and rang the doorbell of the Warmsley residence. George Warmsley was his last victim.
二楼阳台，布莱恩当时没关门。布莱恩把床拖到门口，头朝阳台睡觉，以便在炎热的夜晚享受海风。枪手朝布莱恩的头部开了一枪，然后离开公寓，向东走了五公里来到内德兰兹。到达内德兰兹后，枪手绕到寄宿公寓后面，当时约翰·斯塔基正睡在后阳台上，枪手朝他的头部开了一枪。随后，枪手走到隔壁街道，途中又弹出一个弹壳，并按响了沃姆斯利家的门铃。乔治·沃姆斯利是他最后的受害者。
It didn't appear that any of the victims were connected or had been specifically targeted. No fingerprints had been recovered from any of the crime scenes, nor did police find the murder weapon. All of the shell casings recovered had come from the same 22 gauge firearm, which was a Lithgow single-shot rifle. There were 75,000 such rifles registered in the state of Western Australia. Police began following up on each one in search of the murder weapon, and even extended their search to the eastern states of Australia. They test-fired a total of 60,000 rifles, but none were a match.
受害者之间似乎没有任何联系，也没有迹象表明他们是特定目标。犯罪现场没有提取到任何指纹，警方也没有找到凶器。所有回收的弹壳都来自同一把22口径枪支，即利思戈单发步枪。西澳大利亚州注册了75,000支此类步枪。警方开始逐一排查以寻找凶器，甚至将搜索范围扩大到了澳大利亚东部各州。他们试射了总共60,000支步枪，但没有一支匹配。
There appeared to be a time lapse between the attacks in Coddersloe and those in Netherlands, prompting detectives to wonder if the shooter had used a bike to cycle from the first location to the second. However, some witnesses had reported seeing a light-coloured Holden sedan driving in Coddersloe around the time of the first attacks. What made the sedan suspicious was the fact that its headlights weren't on, even though it was the middle of the night. Witnesses in Netherlands had reported seeing a similar car parked near the crime scenes there. Perth had experienced some ripples of concern in the years immediately preceding the random shootings in late January 1963. The pattern of hit and runs and the reports of a prowler entering and robbing homes before attacking
科德斯洛的袭击与内德兰兹的袭击之间似乎存在时间差，这促使侦探们怀疑枪手是否骑自行车从第一个地点前往第二个地点。然而，一些目击者报告称，在第一次袭击发生时，看到一辆浅色的霍顿轿车在科德斯洛行驶。这辆轿车之所以可疑，是因为尽管当时是深夜，但它的前大灯却没有打开。内德兰兹的目击者报告称，看到一辆类似的车停在当地的犯罪现场附近。在1963年1月下旬发生随机枪击事件之前的几年里，珀斯曾出现过一些不安的涟漪。肇事逃逸的模式以及关于潜行者进入并抢劫房屋后袭击
female residents had both caused a stir. But the Australia Day shootings sent the city into a full-blown panic. Overnight, people completely changed their habits and behaviours in response to the senseless attacks. They locked their doors and made sure to close their windows at night despite the sweltering summer heat. Gun purchases skyrocketed. People slept with weapons by their bed where they could reach them at a moment's notice. Others made do with what they could find, including knives, cricket bats,
女性居民的报道都引起了轰动。但澳大利亚日枪击案让整个城市陷入了彻底的恐慌。一夜之间，人们为了应对这些毫无意义的袭击，彻底改变了他们的习惯和行为。他们锁上门，确保在炎热的夏夜关上窗户。枪支购买量激增。人们睡觉时把武器放在床边，以便随时取用。其他人则凑合使用他们能找到的东西，包括刀具、板球棒，
and even cans of fly spray they could aim directly at an assailant's eyes. Animal shelters suddenly faced a huge demand for guard dogs, with pounds across Perth selling out of dogs. Outhouses were common at the time, but more people started installing toilets inside of their houses so they wouldn't have to go outside at all after dark. Children were no longer allowed to sleep on back verandas to stay cool on hot nights as they'd done in the past. Strange theories about the shootings emerged. Some people falsely confessed to the crimes. Others pointed out that the attacks had taken place during a full moon. In his memoir, The Sharknet, author Robert Drew wrote about how the shootings changed Perth in an instant. Quote, The murders immediately changed the spirit of the place. They chilled the warm shadows of the
甚至是可以直接喷向袭击者眼睛的杀虫喷雾罐。动物收容所突然面临对护卫犬的巨大需求，珀斯各地的收容所里的狗都被抢购一空。当时户外厕所很常见，但更多人开始在屋内安装厕所，这样天黑后他们就根本不用出门了。孩子们不再被允许像过去那样睡在后阳台上以在炎热的夜晚保持凉爽。关于枪击事件的奇怪理论层出不穷。有些人虚假地承认了罪行。另一些人指出，袭击发生在满月期间。作者罗伯特·德鲁在他的回忆录《鲨鱼网》中写道，枪击事件是如何瞬间改变珀斯的。引用：谋杀案立即改变了这个地方的精神面貌。它们让街道两旁
peppermint and box trees and flowering gums lining the streets. The slightly crumbly lines of the brick and limestone houses, the cosy-looking fake Tudor apartment blocks and shop fronts had a sharper, harsher edge. Their facades looked stony and closed. People's eyes flicked away as they hurried indoors or into their cars. Fewer residents went out after dark, creating an eerie atmosphere where the streets were especially quiet at night. Despite the reduced foot and vehicle traffic, the state government arranged to keep streetlights blazing all night long from Nedlands down to Fremantle in a direct response to the shootings.
薄荷树、箱树和开花桉树的温暖阴影变得冰冷。砖石房屋略显破碎的线条、看起来舒适的仿都铎式公寓楼和店面显得更加尖锐、严酷。它们的外墙看起来冷漠而封闭。人们在匆忙进入室内或车内时，眼神会迅速移开。天黑后外出的居民减少了，营造出一种阴森的氛围，街道在晚上格外安静。尽管行人和车辆交通减少，州政府还是安排在整个晚上保持路灯通明，从内德兰兹一直延伸到弗里曼特尔，作为对枪击事件的直接回应。
Police were under intense pressure to solve the case, working day and night to catch the person responsible. Calls flooded in from the public with tip-offs. Sometimes there were so many that they clogged up the switchboard. A special operational room was set up just to manage these calls. While detectives combed over every detail of the Australia Day shootings and break-ins, an additional 40 patrol officers were out on the streets of Perth every night, watching the city from patrol cars, horseback and on foot. Despite this, they failed to identify or apprehend a suspect. Nor were they able to prevent the Prowler attacks, which continued in the wake of the
警方承受着巨大的破案压力，日夜不停地工作以抓获肇事者。公众打来的举报电话如潮水般涌入。有时电话太多，甚至堵塞了总机。警方专门设立了一个特别行动室来处理这些电话。当侦探们仔细梳理澳大利亚日枪击案和入室盗窃案的每一个细节时，每晚还有40名额外的巡逻警察在珀斯街头，通过巡逻车、骑马和步行监视这座城市。尽管如此，他们还是没能确定或逮捕嫌疑人。他们也没能阻止潜行者袭击，这些袭击在
Australia Day shootings, but were believed to be unrelated. Lucy Madrill was murdered less than three weeks after the shootings. Carmel Reed was attacked four months later. It wasn't until August that there would finally be a significant development in the case. To be continued... Music There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
澳大利亚日枪击案后仍在继续，但被认为与此无关。露西·马德里尔在枪击案发生不到三周后被谋杀。卡梅尔·里德在四个月后遭到袭击。直到八月，案件才终于有了重大进展。未完待续……音乐 本集暂无评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。